there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock all right you guys we're back
once again this is episode 116 the one
after the Halloween episode I'm glad
that you guys really seemed to enjoy the
Halloween episode we got like a lot of
really cool comments about that so yeah
we appreciate it like I said apologies
again and a couple of you I contacted
you know that I couldn't read some of
your stuff on there cuz it was too long
and stuff so again I apologize for that
yeah it'd have been like a nine-hour
show it probably would have been yeah um
actually somebody made a suggestion that
maybe we should do like another offshoot
show that is just like reader
submissions like fiction or nonfiction
or something like that that's actually a
good idea I actually did think that was
a good idea because every time we do one
of those it seems like really popular
and we always get like a lot of really
good submissions so we might look into
doing that in the future I mean we've
already got three shows a week yes well
it's gonna depend on patreon support I
mean it would really have to do because
look at how much that eats into book
production yeah true
alright I mean we we're still trying to
get the audio book out for theses
villain - yeah it's recorded and she
hasn't gotten through the editing yet
yeah cuz well no time to head it yeah it
just takes so long and it's like you
know we have so much other stuff going
on that it's land Jenni's graphic design
demands have just skyrocketed you know
she's got these new clients that wanted
to design all this packages you're some
badass packages too and we got some free
products where is that yes I've never
had this flavor oh it's good but the
mint the mint flavor was really good now
this is actually a different this isn't
matcha tea this is actually turmeric
yeah based type of tea and you can also
make golden milk with it yeah they have
a hibiscus flavor and a chocolate flavor
I actually at one of the meetings where
we were doing the package design
kind of ideas for it I actually they let
me try both flavors and they are both
fantastic they're seriously they're
delicious
cuz I you know I love turmeric type
stuff so it actually did kind of taste
like it actually kind of tastes like a
Thai soup or something like that yeah
that one oh that one mint that you had I
made like a ice yeah iced tea with it
yeah with cream and think sugar and a
bunch of ice that it came out kind of
green and man it was good yeah there
macho's almost kind of like a shake yeah
they're matcha lion I think they have
like seven different flavors but
actually the men's is my favorite that's
not cheap either that that's it well no
it's good stuff I mean you know what I
mean this stuff I mean the matcha is
like source from Japan it's like all
right high quality stuff so you know
healing butterfly have to want to go
check them out yeah just it makes like
the heart the boxers these come in hard
boxes too much so you should go check
out the store and not let's see what
else let's do our last movie review
which was the weird 2001 serial killer
supernatural mystery frailty which is on
shudder absolute if you want to go watch
it it was kind of like a weird I think
it was kind of like an off-the-wall sort
of choice but maybe not cuz I guess it's
kind of like Anna people seem to like it
yeah and it's like a lot of people were
like ah it's gotten classic yeah it
really is it's like you know so and so
we like to do ones that are kind of cult
classics or ones that are kind of a
little bit forgotten about so go check
that out if you haven't already I want
to see that another one that was kind of
like it the one about the apocalypse I
haven't seen that the rapture rapture
haven't seen that in forever I think
people have forgot about that even more
like what if we actually did happen what
if pocalypse was happening cuz I
remember that one not being so much a
horror movie that was kind of more an
apocalyptic drama I want to call it yeah
I don't mind uh Connie it was kind of
sentiments it was kind of spooky because
you're cut you're approaching that your
approach and it as if you know
apocalyptic you know apocalyptic
religious beliefs are [ __ ] that's
right he approached it but then all of a
sudden you know knows this happening
this is happening yeah you know that was
a weird movie I've seen in a long time I
saw it many many years ago but I
remembered it it made an impression I
remember
what happened in it but yeah we should
actually try to seek that yeah I was
like actually like a good version of of
what was that all sorts [ __ ] movie this
is terrible oh yes
seven signs in the days yeah yeah and
days wonder now the end of days
one of the worst Arnold Schwarzenegger
movies I told you it was bad you know I
mean what it was I got to do a show on
the worst of Arnold and I'm a huge
Arnold Schwarzenegger fan but then
you're the one you should do it because
you have so much love for him that
you're not just gonna like [ __ ] on him
for no reason you know come tell you why
that there was bad Arnold there was
there was really bad Arnold there was
yeah
well I think most actors that have been
around as long as he is you're gonna do
some bad movies you're gonna do some but
it's just inevitable you might as well
just lean into it because it's gonna
happen almost all new actors out there
was good in sci-fi fantasy that's what I
think yeah and things like Conan
fantasy-type
and like I said now see now that he's
older and can actually play a normal
person instead of like an uber man
surely kind of like a superhero type
character yeah um I definitely feel like
he's got acting chops like he can act
like a normal person when you get in the
role but I don't think he would have
been able to do that when he was younger
it's time for him to come up with some
weird [ __ ] I wanted to do King Conan
maybe they might get to that yeah I
wanted to do King Kong they might get to
that yeah and I think the only other
thing um like I said check out our
latest matinee review which was episode
4 kind of had a strange conglomeration
of movies as past week it was like the
end of October and yeah wiping out then
we're just like what can we see without
you know having to see a star is born
because I really don't want to see that
but um we ended up actually the the
movies we saw were actually not as bad
as I was expecting we ended up seeing
small feet can't I can't would turn out
to be bro right I really liked small
foot actually we're all okay yeah they
were all okay hunter-killer was all
right Johnny English strikes again that
yeah watch like British spy movie throw
it out and said that was like it was
pretty entertaining um this week I think
will be better because there's more
movies that we actually were really
excited about coming out sauces Furio
yeah Suspiria
I think Bohemian Rhapsody and we got to
pick another one for this week - but
that'll be the one that will come out
next week so we won't spoil it by saying
what we thought about cuz we saw says
berry already so anyway let's see what
else oh I also recorded a an interview
with Adam seen from conspiratorial the
people over at our friends over at spear
and or Mille this was actually another
true crime show because faceless villain
to is so long we actually did I was on
there once like talking about crimes
from the 1960s and this one we were
actually talking about crimes from the
1970s
so I'm don't know if it's gonna be up by
the time this show goes up but I'll put
a link it if it is and if it's not then
I'll put a link whenever it does come
out and also on their patreon page there
will be like bonus material of just of
you know of Tom and me and just talking
about random [ __ ]
so like Bolton ro and stuff like that so
check that out if you have the time or
the inclination and speaking of patreon
obviously as I say every time if you
want to support the show and go to our
patreon page at patreon.com slash 13
o'clock 13 o'clock there do protein flip
[Laughter]
like when it comes around all the way
around up to the top and a little bit
it's like a carousel okay that's exactly
what it but I was going to say our
latest patreon donor who's name is
Justin so thank you very much just
another heavy-hitter also we had a a fan
named Jason who made a very generous
PayPal donation this past week so thank
you very much I don't know about that
one guys yeah okay yeah I tell them
things and he forgets it just goes in
one ear and out the other
so anyway today again since we did like
kind of paranormal a creepy [ __ ] on the
last show which was the Halloween
episode this time I'm gonna go back and
do some true crime now these two cases
were both separately
requested by various people and these
are actually two cases that I've
actually been interested in for a very
long time the first of these is not
necessarily its true crime but it's
there there's one murder maybe although
it might not be a murder and there was
an attempted murder but mostly this is
just like a weird crazy convoluted like
unsolved mystery and actually I first
heard about this case on unsolved
mysteries back in the 1990s they did it
they did a partial episode about this
and I just watched it I think even when
they redid the show with Dennis Farina
they repackaged this segment because
this was actually one of their most
famous segments just this case is just
so [ __ ] bizarre so it's known as the
circle bill writer case or the circle
bill letters so we'll get into that in
the first half of the show and then last
half the show I'm gonna be talking about
more standard true crime thing an
uncaught serial killer and kind of one
that flew under the radar in the 1970s
known as the doodler or the black
doodler who has never been caught so and
both of these kind of started in the
1970s so we're going with the 70s true
crime theme on this episode walk walk
walk yeah wah-wah-wah-wah yeah okay so
let's start talking about now I gave you
a little bit of a rundown of kind of the
main point yeah I don't know much about
this case I'm kind of like just the
experimental stand-in for the for the
audience if I don't understand it maybe
they don't understand it you know it
depends on how smart they are happen
price more than maybe well the law of
averages would sound like a nice little
song like perhaps by They Might Be
Giants but anyway okay so let's talk
about the Circleville writer case and
like I said this this has a lot of
moving parts and there's a lot of like
kind of really bizarre [ __ ] going on
with this so I'm gonna try and keep it
all straight for you guys most of you
might have heard of it cuz like I said
it kind of got a lot of traction in the
1990s when it was on unsolved mysteries
one of their famous segments so this
started
sometime either in late 1976 or early
1977 there's this little town called
Circleville Ohio about 25 miles outside
of Columbus kind of a small town only
about 14,000 people live there you know
one of those places you don't lock your
doors and all this other kind of stuff
well beginning in like I said late 76
early 1977 various people around the
town start getting these very strange
and threatening letters now most of them
are written in this kind of block text
like someone's trying to disguise their
handwriting like they're writing in all
caps and they're just writing in like
these weird block letters now a lot of
the letters like some we're very you
know vulgar or they'll you're swearing a
lot of them seem to no private details
about the people that the letters are
targeted toward and like I said I think
over the course of this and this was a
something that went on for you know many
many years I think over the course of
this thing like about a thousand letters
were sent now they call it Circleville
writer I think it's more than one person
but we'll get into that a little bit
later on so even though a lot of people
around the town had gotten these letters
the people that seemed to be targeted
particularly was this woman named Mary
Gillespie now Mary Gillespie was a
school bus driver now sometime in 1976
or early 1977 she received a threatening
letter that basically said I know about
your affair
with the superintendent of schools whose
name was Gordon Massey and you need to
knock that [ __ ] off or else something
Bad's gonna happen they were threats
pretty much now she got I'm not sure how
many of these letters that she got um I
think the unsolved mysteries episode
said it was - but it might have been
more than that I've never seen any
sources saying exactly how many she got
she kept them a secret from her husband
Ron she just kind of like ignored them
even though some of them seemed to
threaten her daughter who was 12 years
old at the time
so she kept it under wraps but then the
husband Ron Gillespie he got one as well
and this letter said go like you need to
go to the school board and report your
wife's affair with the superintendent of
schools or else something Bad's gonna
happen to you you know bloody MIT was
threatening his life essentially so at
this point
okay so Ron says what the hell is this
all about Mary says that's a lie I'm not
having an affair with that guy I don't
know what the hell this is all about so
at this stage I mean they they decide to
contact don't think they initially went
to the police the first thing they did
was they kind of contacted their family
members at this point this was like
Ron's sister Karen and her husband Paul
and they kind of like invited him over
the house is like what do you make of
all this and let him let them read some
of the letters so there was no affair
like I said this is a plot and the plot
oh the plots gonna thicken a lot this is
this [ __ ] just gets weirder and are they
you couldn't have written something like
this in a novel and people would believe
it it's you wouldn't buy it so they're
discussing this [ __ ] with their family
members now I think that in a lot of
kind of things that I've seen about the
Circleville writer case especially stuff
that's not real in-depth about it's just
kind of like a you know like a little
you know summary of it they generally
say oh they all had these big block
letters but what a lot of sources that I
kind of once I kind of went down the
rabbit hole they're like no there were
actually two different kinds of letters
there were the block letter e ones and
then there were some that had some kind
of more normal-looking handwriting but
were signed with a W because it should
be noted that the block letter ones
there was obviously no return address
they were not signed the only thing that
was on the envelope is a postmark and
the postmark was from Columbus Ohio
which as I said was 25 miles away from
Circleville which is you know where all
of the people that were targeted by
these letters lived so this
somebody mailing stuff from Columbus but
knows all this intrigue about people
that are going on in this little town 25
miles away so the family gets together
and I'm not sure now they thought they
knew who the letter writer was now I've
seen some sources say that
Gordon Massey who was the superintendent
of schools who Mary Gillespie was
supposedly having an affair with he had
a teenage son named William so they were
thinking that maybe William had written
some of the letters particularly the
ones signed with the W because I mean it
was his dad having an affair so maybe he
would have some kind of motive for doing
that now evidently they decided that
they were going to send a bunch of
letters they were gonna write letters
presumably to William but I'm not
entirely sure about that like different
sources say different things if I'm not
sure if that's who they suspected or if
it was someone else but so whoever it
was they suspected they're like okay
well we're gonna write them letters not
threatening him but saying look we know
who you are and you need to knock it off
so they wrote like four or five letters
to this person that they suspected of
being the letter writer now this did
actually kind of seem to work because
the letters seemed to kind of you know
go I don't know if they stopped entirely
but they did kind of like you know there
weren't as many of them showing up so
this all kind of went you know the
letters kind of went fallow and stuff
like that but then comes August 19th
1977
now Mary Gillespie is out of town she is
on vacation in Florida along with Karen
who is her sister-in-law and two other
women now allegedly she has been going
down to Florida and she's gonna meet
Gordon Massey who she denied you know
having an affair with him like from the
start but no one buys that everybody
thinks she really was having an affair
with him the whole entire time but
I'll get into that a little bit later so
she's down in Florida with her
girlfriends now her husband Ron is at
home according to the children he gets a
phone call and the phone call is
presumably from the letter writer nobody
knows what this person said on the phone
but it pissed Ron off mightily he says
to his kids I'm gonna go get this guy he
gets his gun and he goes and he gets in
his pickup truck and he takes off a
short time later Ron is found dead in
his pickup truck at an intersection not
far away the truck has hit a tree
what and has and he's dead okay now his
gun has been discharged one time they
think but they never did find the bullet
casing or anything like that they didn't
see where the bullet went they're not
entirely sure when it was fired but they
think it was sometime after he left the
house they also find that his blood
alcohol level is 0.16 which his kids
think is very strange because they said
you know he didn't really drink either
at all or all that often
and he didn't seem to be drunk when he
left could it have been an error um it
could have been but I'm not really sure
so in any case like I said Mary
Gillespie and them are out of town
they're in Florida
she's ostensibly boinking someone else
well hold on hold on I'm trying to
picture this crime scene here or this
accident scene he's at an intersection
the car is rammed into a tree yep now it
was this a particularly dangerous
intersection nobody saw this not that I
know it not that I ever saw is there any
evidence that he was driven off the road
not that I ever saw
he must have acts so mad he just ran off
the road it's possible I'm kind of
leaning toward because see the the thing
is like all this weird [ __ ] that
happened later has led to some people
saying well that was murder but I'm not
entirely sure about that I've been an
accident
it might have been so in any way so Ron
Gillespie is dead right because his
truck is hit a tree
so they you know during the
investigation like initially they
thought oh well maybe it's foul play and
they kind of like talk to a suspect
about it but after that suspect was
released then it seemed like most of the
authorities said no it wasn't foul play
it was just an accident you know he was
drunk and he was angry because this
person had called and you know so
evidently he just ran off the road
because he was drunk and mad so that's
kind of where they left it now
after that happened you know there were
still like more letters coming and all
this other kind of [ __ ] and this kind of
went on for years and years now
interestingly after Braun died in the
accident then Mary Gillespie came out
and said yes I am sleeping with with
Gordon Massey but we didn't start our
relationship until after the letters had
started arrived which I don't buy that
actually nobody buys that yeah I think
it was kind of just a way for her to
save face I mean at that point her
reputation had already been ruined
because everybody heard about I mean
she's still had her job and everything
like that but you know everybody knew
about the letters and the you know the
accusations the affair and stuff like
that so I think she was just trying to
save face she's like oh my husband is
dead now at that point Gordon Massey had
divorced his wife so you know so they
could date and it wouldn't be like a big
deal but I don't but I think she was
having an affair with him the whole
entire time some kind of connection and
was just trying to yeah some kind of
connection with the women in this story
yes I was either watching her I was
watching the other guy's wife yeah about
it that way some weird going on yeah
like I said and again no it gets weirder
he's got a known well yeah because he
knew like a lot of into details about
their stuff no like I said some of the
letters were sent to other people in the
city too like City Council members you
know various other people in the school
system and seem to know [ __ ] about them
as well so but like I said the Gillespie
family seemed to be the main target of
the ire okay so now that the affair is
out in the open now in 1983 which as I
said this is many years later this
these letters have been kind of going on
this whole time in 1983 Mary Gillespie
as I said she's a school bus driver and
she's been a school bus driver this
whole entire time she's driving her
route she's driving kids home from
school on her bus it's about 3:30 p.m.
she sees a sign that's like tied to a
fence post or a signpost that is
directly threatening her daughter like I
said a lot of the the letters threatened
her daughter that said that she was
gonna shoot her daughter in the head if
various things didn't happen I believe
some sources said that other signs had
popped up before that threatening the
daughter and some times before Ron
Gillespie died he would get up really
early and drive around town and take
these signs down so that other kids or
other people wouldn't see them so this
wasn't the first time that this had
happened but so she's driving down the
street at 3:30 in the afternoon she sees
a sign that's directly threatening her
child so she pulls the bus over and she
pulls the sign off the fence post now
the sign has been put on there was like
twine also attached to the fence post
with the same twine is a box she opens
up the box and the twine is also tied to
the trigger of a 25 caliber pistol that
is inside the box it is essentially a
crude booby trap that was ostensibly
supposed to go off when she either
pulled the sign off the fence post or
when she opened the box the gun did not
go off but this like I said attempted
murder right because this is was
obviously meant for her I mean it was
meant for on her bus route and [ __ ] like
that
so the pistol has had its serial numbers
partially filed off but whoever did this
didn't do a very good job of it so when
they take the pistol into police custody
they are able to get a serial number off
of the pistol yeah in case you guys
don't know how this is done clue you
guys in on some cool [ __ ] Oh
usually a pistol serial number or any
kind of stealing I'm on a firearm just
been kind
roll stamped in there all right so when
that happens this is it's used it's a
machine it's kind of punching the metal
in to form that number when it does that
the metal is more dense there so there's
certain kind of acids you can brush on
there and it'll eat things away except
the highly dense metal where it's been
punched so the numbers start coming
starts become visible pretty neat huh
yeah because it's dent more dense there
that's how they do that file in a number
down won't do it you can file it pretty
much all the way down and that density
of that punch is prevalent deep deep
into that metal the only way is to drill
it out yeah well that was not done and
like I said I don't even think it was
completely filed off like I said whoever
did it did kind of a piss-poor job yeah
just trying oh yeah and I have some
theories about why that might be
probably a frame somebody else yeah
that's fit that's very that's kind of
what I'm leaning toward yeah so they
they find the the serial number of the
gun and they trace the gun back to UM
Ron's brother-in-law Ron was the one
that got killed in the car accident you
remember this is Ron's brother-in-law
Paul fresh our now he was one of the
first guys that they showed the letters
to right it's his gun so they asked him
in there like look he's like I didn't
why would I want to kill Mary Gillespie
you know why would I want to do that
even though the gun was his but he said
yeah but I used to keep it in the garage
and I haven't even looked at it or
checked on it in a really long time who
the [ __ ] knows somebody could have broke
in and taken it it's like you know a
million things could have happened so it
sounded [ __ ] e but they I mean they
arrested him anyway and then they're
like okay well if this was your gun and
you set up this sign and the booby trap
and everything like that then you must
also be the circle the letter writer so
here's the dumb thing the [ __ ]
sheriff whose name was Ratcliffe he does
a quote unquote handwriting analysis
where he basically tells Paul fresh our
here are some of the Circleville letter
letters copy them as closely as you can
so Paul's like okay
so then he like writes them out and he's
like aha
you're the circle because you tried to
make it like look it's like I said they
were block letters right so this besides
this like dumbest handwriting Alice's
ever so paul rush hour is arrested for
attempted murder now he's not arrested
he's not charged with writing the
letters which would be harassment and
various other things in stalking and
whatnot he's not arrested for that but
at his trial they're allowed to
introduce them as evidence as though he
has written them even though he denied
writing them he said the only letters
that I wrote he said were the ones that
we wrote we were at four or five letters
to the person that we suspected of being
the Circleville writer you know at the
beginning of this whole brouhaha he's
like I did write those but he's like
those weren't threatening we just said
hey we know who you are knock it off
that's about all we said cops and
lawyers sometimes left on their own do
some crazy [ __ ] well I kind of feel like
and I don't you know I don't know and
you can't trust lawyers at all either
well they I kind of feel like the
sheriff was kind of behind a lot of this
stuff I don't know if it's if I buy like
a lot of the conspiracy theory stuff but
for sure I think he was just looking for
a suspect and wanted to put the whole
thing behind him he's just like yeah you
did it whatever yeah
so essentially so pompfresh our even
though so basically they're like okay so
they used the letters against him even
though there was this whole dumb thing
and they couldn't prove that he had
actually written em and he denied
writing them even in the gun was his
even though he said look it's been in my
garage forever I didn't even know it was
gone I don't ever I don't shoot it I'll
have any ammo for it
they actually searched his house and
they found nothing that would have had
they didn't find any twine they didn't
find any ammunition for the gun anything
that would have suspect you know that
would have made you suspect that he had
made the the bomb or whatever the booby
trap or whatever so they didn't find
anything his fingerprints were not on
any the letters his fingerprints were on
the gun nothing but yet he was still
convicted of attempted murder seven to
twenty five years right okay you know
just to make things clear to the
audience give it a choice between the
average cop and the average law
I trust the average cop over the average
lawyer you need any day I wouldn't trust
either one of them no I
the average cop at least season these at
10th tends to be kind of just a
reasonable regular guy the average
lawyer a lot of times tends to be kind
of idealistic and got something to prove
and trying to make a name and little is
just lawyers lawyers and cops but you
got to have you got to have cops at
least and Negus you had to have lawyers
well yeah lawyers are the you know
lawyers are the modern secular version
of the priest class really you know
writing magical spells to make things to
come to fruition in the real world you
know they're like sorcerers so here's
the thing Paul fresh hour is put in
prison now you would think that had he
been the Circleville writer that the
letters would stop once he went to
prison they did not so obviously it
wasn't him but the sheriff was so still
convinced that it was him that he was
still saying no he somehow sending them
from prison or he's like having them
smuggled out even though the warden of
the prison was like there's no way it's
like we took away all this writing which
ever even they put him in solitary
confinement and all of a sudden there's
like there's no way that he could be
writing these letters because the
letters ramped up after he went to
prison so there's that whole thing going
on too so these like there's no way that
he could be writing them and plus it
should be noted too that the circle bill
letters every single one of them was
postmarked Columbus Ohio and Paul fresh
hour was in prison in a town called Lima
90 miles away so they're like there's
just there's no way so he's sitting
there in jail meanwhile the letters are
still coming in fact Paul fresh hour
gets a letter from the Circleville
writer himself and it says now when are
you going to believe you aren't going to
get out of there I told you two years
ago when we set him up they stay set up
don't you listen at all it said that so
he got his own letter that said that so
obviously this is like I said a frame-up
now in 1990
fresh hour comes up for parole even
though he has been a model prisoner
the sheriff is able to say oh well the
letters kept coming and obviously it's
still him so you can't let him out so
they didn't so he stayed in he didn't
get out on parole until 1994 he'd been
in prison for ten years false charges
yeah yeah this is some [ __ ] right
I'm saying that our test lawyers now see
the thing about Paul fresh our I not
only do really really I really do not
think I mean he passed away in 2012 if
you want to go he if you do like I
searched Paul fresh our Circleville
letters or something like that
he actually after he got out of prison
he put up this big website I think it's
like a hundred and sixty four pages I
kind of skimmed through I read some of
it he was trying to get the FBI involved
and he was like you know talking about
all these things that had been you know
not admitted at his trial that would
have probably gotten him off and all
this other stuff now a lot of this stuff
some of the stuff that he said on there
was a little far-fetched like you know
he was saying this sheriff was like
complicit in like covering up murders
and various other things so I think he
went a little far but some of the [ __ ] I
kind of bought like I could buy that he
kind of got railroaded into this kind of
[ __ ] cuz check this [ __ ] out
later on there was like a an independent
like an investigative journalist and he
got interested in this case it was a
Martin Yant I think and he was the one
that brought the case to the attention
of unsolved mysteries so he started
working on the case started interviewing
people that had to do with it and
everything started interviewing Paul
fresh our they started working together
and what they discovered was that there
had been some stuff that had not been
brought out at Paul fresh hours trial
the main thing that had not come out was
that on the day that the that Mary
Gillespie found the booby-trap on her
bus route there was another witness that
said that 20 minutes before Mary
Gillespie found it that this other bus
driver saw somebody standing by the
fence post a man and a yellow El Camino
that he looked like he was doing
something but like he tried to like not
show his face like he was peeing or
something and they said they thought
that was very weird
now this but other bus driver described
this person as like a sandy-haired like
a blond man which is not what paul fresh
hour looked like also Paul fresh hour
did not have a yellow El Camino yeah
hard to hide and alchemy but guess who
did
Paul fresh hours ex-wife because Paul
fresh hour and Karen fresh hour had
divorced in 1982 her brother had a
yellow El Camino and the guy's standing
by the fence post looked a lot like her
current boyfriend so they didn't say
that at the trial and the interesting
thing too is that the whole accusations
of Paul fresh our being the Circleville
writer Karen didn't start saying that
until after the divorce because in the
divorce Paul fresh our got the house and
the kids so some people are thinking
here's the thing I'm kind of gonna go
let me go a little bit down here like I
said now Paul fresh our he has since
passed away he passed away in 2012 but
he was kind of working on this you know
a lot until he died and he's like I said
the website is still there if you want
to go read all his letters and stuff um
the interesting thing is that I think
and a lot of it seems like a leather a
lot of other people who have looked
really deep into this case kind of feel
like the same thing I think this is -
not unrelated necessarily but two
separate incidents
I think the first letters that arrived
the accused Mary Gillespie of having an
affair with Gordon Massey the
Superintendent of Schools I think that
maybe a few of them came from Gorton
Gordon Massey's son although I don't
know you know it wasn't all of them and
it and maybe it wasn't any of them
because he did maybe have a reason to
but he was a teenager it's like why
would he care that much he wasn't the
letter writer because there's no way
he'd send like a thousand letters like
no teenage boy would do that so maybe he
wrote a couple of them maybe not
I think the initial letters accusing her
of the affair came from a co-worker of
hers whose name was David long Barry
now David long Barry allegedly I'm not
sure what his job was but he might have
been another bus driver he worked in the
school system and he knew her allegedly
he had a big crush on her and had asked
her out and she had said no and then
started sleeping with Gordon Massey so
there was some jealousy issues that
sounds like that sounds like that might
be and it sounds like he kind of had a
motive so I feel like the first series
of letters that were all like that were
directed at her and directed at Ron
Gillespie saying in blue why don't you
report the affair to the school board do
something about it I'm gonna kill your
daughter that kind of stuff I kind of
feel like that was probably long Barry
now it should be noted that many years
later I believe it was in 1999 David
long Barry was sought for raping an
11-year old girl he was staying in his
house with like this elderly couple and
the 11 year old girl was their
granddaughter and this guy allegedly
rapes this girl while the grandparents
are in the house yeah so they were
looking for him for that and he went on
the run and ended up hanging himself
later on this I think was in 1999 so
this guy obviously not the most stable
individual yeah so I'm kind of feeling
like the original Circleville letters
were probably from him the block letter
ones and then you know after Ron
Gillespie died which I kind of suspect
was maybe just a weird coincidence and
was just like an accident um I kind of
feel like I don't know like about the
gun being discharged that seems a little
weird but I mean it could just how do
they know the wind that gun was right
you don't know what a [ __ ] are the
weeks before or it's like he might have
just shot out the window cuz he was mad
or right you know he was drunk
apparently so
you know there could have been a million
reasons why that might have happened I
don't necessarily think that he was
murdered or that had anything to do with
it I think that the letter writer who
I'm assuming is David long Barry called
him and said something that pissed him
off so much
that he said I'm gonna go get this guy
he probably told him where he was just
coming down here meeting yeah come down
here meet me I gotta tell you something
or something like that he's like I'm
gonna go get this [ __ ] God is
gone and maybe he even drank like for
courage or whatever or he was already
drunk and he was just inclined to like
go off and I think he just got in an
accident I don't think that was a murder
I don't think anything like that now I
think after that happened after um Paul
fresh hour and Karen his wife got
divorced in the in 1982 which was by all
accounts a very very acrimonious divorce
I think she decided because she knew
about the letters she'd read them like
when they were still married you know
when they were over at the Gillespie's
house so she said I'm gonna use that you
know to frame Paul fresher because she
was pissed off at him he got the house
he got the kids and Martin Yant who was
the investigative journalist who worked
on this many years later said that he
had talked to her and she was a very
angry very vindictive woman and he said
it's very interesting that she didn't
say anything about Paul fresh our being
the Circleville writer until after the
divorce he's like if she really thought
that why didn't he say why didn't she
say that in the door searing like that
she thought but she didn't say anything
about that there's no mention of it it
was only after the divorce and after
that happened that you know that she
went off and said oh he wrote all those
letters and he tried to kill Mary
Gillespie with the booby trap and all
this other kind of [ __ ]
so I kind of suspect like I said this is
two separate incidents I think the first
one was the was the jealous guy the
co-worker that loved Mary Gillespie and
was mad that she'd started an affair
with another guy so she was so he was
trying to out her you know get her in
trouble with her husband break up her
marriage and that killed and he had no
recourse no way to stop it right and
then you know the husband got killed
which like I said was probably just like
a strange coincidence and so the letters
kind of stopped after that but then I
think after the fresh hours got divorced
I think Karen said I'm gonna use that
letter writer thing and just make
everybody think it's the same person and
frame and because here's the thing Karen
used to live in the house with Paul
fresh our obvious
because they were married she knew where
that gun was hmm how easy would it be to
go in the garage because she knew that
her husband didn't like to really use it
he just kept it stashed in there how
easy would it be for her to take it and
then sort of half-assedly try to scrape
the thing off so it's like oh well I'm
trying to hide right whose gun it is but
not really you know what I mean it would
be easier for to do that and I think she
probably recruited her boyfriend at the
time whose name I do not know I didn't
see it in anywhere I think she recruited
her boyfriend at the time to help her do
that so they would be able to frame him
hmm now I forgot to mention too that
when unsolved mysteries was doing was
researching the you know the segment
about this case they got a circle billed
letter right let her do it was like an
anonymous post card and it said forget
Circleville Ohio and then it said
something like don't hurt Sheriff
Ratcliffe I don't know why it would have
said that trying to frame him yeah but
um but then it also said you if you I
can't read but it said something like if
you do this story like you UL sickos
will pay yeah and then it was signed the
Circleville writer yeah I think Karen
wrote that and a lot of other
researchers on the internet seem to
agree with me I think that I think Karen
wrote that but as far as I know that was
the last one but like I said this is
like this is the weirdest [ __ ] case
like it has so many moving parts to it
and you know like I said I think it was
just two things you kind of get
conflated into one ring but I definitely
think there was at least two letter
writers probably Haitian and it became a
copycat case later right so you know
like I said I'm not saying I don't know
if Gordon Massey's son wrote any of the
letters because a couple of them did
have different handwriting and were
signed with the W so he might have
written a few of them but I don't think
I mean I think mostly it was the
co-worker and then later Karen took up
or Karen or the boyfriend you know they
were working in tandem to try to get
Paul fresh ever in trouble which
actually worked because he was in prison
for ten years and then even after he got
out and he was trying to get the FBI to
investigate a new
to get her prosecuted and all this other
kind of stuff and as far as I know that
never went anywhere and he passed away
so like I said this is like a [ __ ]
strange case and there's a lot of really
cool [ __ ] out there about it
there's [ __ ] I've looked there was a
really good podcast
the trail went cold he did a lot of
really good research about it's about an
hour long and that's really good so I
would recommend listening to that but
you know I think going through most of
this I think most of the other people
that have researched the case have come
to a similar conclusion as what I did
now some more conspiracy might and say
oh maybe Ron Gillespie maybe that was a
murder which it could have been but I'm
kind of leaning toward no I'm kind of
leaning toward it was just an accident
and it just it just seemed weird because
it was such a coincidence that he had
been threatened and him and his wife had
been threatened and then he ended up
dead you know so could it have been a
murder yeah but it seemed like a really
convoluted way to murder somebody yeah
and honestly the booby trap thing I'm
not sure if that was even intended to go
off you know what I mean
yes it's still attempted murder but I
think that if Karen and the boyfriend
put that booby trap there I don't think
they really intended it for it to go off
and kill Mary Gillespie I think they
just put it there to scare her you know
what I mean yeah because they would have
done a better job you would think I mean
I heard that the boyfriend was kind of
like a tinkerer he kind of got like he
knew how to do that kind of [ __ ] so if
he if he were gonna made a booby trap he
would have a bit more space to work
right so I just kind of feel like that
was put there to frighten her all right
into whatever but yeah so that's that
case like I said there's a ton of really
good [ __ ] about this because surprised
out of time take a break down it
probably is yeah okay but yeah so we're
gonna take a break right now right at
the halfway point and when we come back
we're going to talk about yet another
uncaught serial killer
the doodler from 1970s San Francisco
dude there why how's that work I will
not bore guy is a serial killer but it's
like I I kind of wish I kind of wish
that the media would give more serial
killers names like that cuz then maybe
they'd knock it off it sounds like Cyril
the old Batman series and next the
doodler yeah you know as funny as I was
watching a documentary I was on YouTube
and somebody
commented that exact same day he said it
sounds exactly like a bat band Phil yeah
and it's like maybe they should give
they should get more serial killers like
goofy ass nicknames like that maybe they
wouldn't do it as much yeah so we're
gonna take a break right now and we'll
be back in just a few minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay everybody Ginny's got some new
shirts designs up four of them really
good ones to Atlanta Ripper who put
Bella in the which out the HH Holmes
murder castle and of course demon child
cuz man said he could these are updated
designs I think they look really cool
Jenny did a great job
bottom where they found making jetty
they were very fun and thank you very
much I think they came out very good
they're very high quality shirts Jenny
and I we're sure our own shirts at
certain times when we're trying to put
spotlight on ourselves and you can put a
spotlight on yourselves if you go ahead
and pick up on these shirts today you
guys are gonna love them links in the
description WWL comm at 13 o'clock yeah
so go check out our store at wwl com /
13 o'clock we got these four cool new
t-shirt designs plus all our old ones if
you'd rather get one of the old ones but
these ones are awesome and you should
check them out they're also available in
women's cut and they look really cute
JD's got some so thank you go check them
out
[Music]
okay we're back and now we're discussing
the second case on our true crime twofer
this is a serial killer called the
doodler sometimes called the black
dealer because he was reportedly an
african-american man this is another one
of those series of black guys doodling
yeah well unlike I said I'll get to why
they call them that this is another one
of those ones because remember that show
we did about the Atlanta Ripper and I
was just kind of like man this guy
killed like all these people and yet
hardly anybody has ever heard of him and
the same thing kind of applies with the
doodler um he sort of comes up on a lot
of these kind of like creepy like under
you know under known serial killers and
stuff like that but there's not a hell
of a lot of information about the case
and we got a good shirt on the Atlanta
Ripper Jenny made a really cool one
that's up there now right yeah because
we fixed we fixed the church the shirt
Channel yeah we had it we had that one
messed up why was it messed up I was
like yeah well why they weren't coming
up they weren't coming up they said they
were public and yet people were like
half the people were saying they
couldn't see them and have to be yeah
they could see there's a radio you had
to read them for Gigi I never would get
how we know oh yeah yeah yeah you can
see it there it's pretty cool yeah it
looks like a it looks like a Jack the
Ripper thing this is a similar kind of
thing this is like another serial killer
that you know there were a lot of them
in the 70s particularly in California
where this took place as well and it
seems like you know serial killers that
even had less victims than this guy
ostensibly did are a lot better known so
again I think I there's probably some
reasons for that I might get into a
little bit later but so this guy
apparently his reign of terror
went from early in 1974 to about fall of
1975
he's usually credited with 14 murders
and three attempted murders like three
people escaped however whenever you look
him up there are only five named victims
so I'm not sure because here's the
problem this particular serial killer
targeted almost exclusively as far as
they know gay men in the Castro district
of San Francisco in the 1970s when it
was still not cool to be gay even in San
Francisco the problem was at this time
period and in this particular place a
lot of gay men were you know coming to
San Francisco because it was more
welcoming than where they were coming
from which didn't say a lot but the
problem was the more of them came there
the more killers seemed to target them I
mean there was a an alarming amount of
gay men murdered in this time period in
this area okay I'm like it was legal
right it pretty much it's just kind of
like I mean anytime you have a
marginalized community I think the same
thing happened with the Atlanta Ripper
because they were all black women the
same thing happened with the case of the
freeway phantom because all the victims
were black girls you know same thing
happened with you know highway of tears
and stuff like that because they're
mostly they were indigenous women it
wasn't the good old days this [ __ ] went
on into the eighties right so when when
your victims come from a sort of
marginalized community or a community
that a lot of people don't have sympathy
for empathy for you're not gonna get a
lot of investigation into the matter and
I think that was kind of what happened
in this case a lot of it has to do with
also just like the police workforce and
and and what their manpower requirements
were that man our requirements because
Jen and I were talking about it earlier
really you know the the crime was so bad
in the United States during the 70s and
80s and even certain times in the past
like back in the 20s and the 30s it kind
of came and came and went and he's weird
weird waves well you know it wasn't an
information society there was no
internet there
no social media or anything like that it
was a bunch of isolated individuals
inside a city he had a police force that
was trying to maintain law and order
against a just a wave a crime wave so
really they they couldn't control the
crime you know it was it's a joke to
think they could control the crime so
what they did is he just kind of
prioritized it yeah they had to triage
yeah sending directly to the rich people
protect the rich people cuz that's who's
given that's who employs the police all
right yeah and the taxpayers because if
you can protect the taxpayers then you
can get reelected all right so people
who didn't pay taxes or people who were
not making much money we're way down low
on the priority there was just no way
and they could barely take care of the
middle class and the upper class really
they could they just kind of made a show
of taking care of them cuz they got
killed too but if you were up if you
were poor you were [ __ ] basically you
were on your own I think that's always
been the case yeah in the end it's
always [ __ ] I don't really care what
your mindset is or what your you know
your value system is in the end you got
to protect yourself that's just the way
it is I think the same thing I think
that's why they never caught the
Cleveland towards murder so like it's
just targeting like people at I hope
okay I'm kids of [ __ ] yeah like yeah
they were nuisances anyway we can't you
know we're not making any money off
those people and they cost crimes and
he's killing people that cause crime I
think the same thing happens when serial
killers target prostitutes I mean unless
they unless they rack up a significant
body count and people start complaining
you know then it's like oh I kill a
couple prostitutes no yeah it took them
all terrible but it's I think that's the
truth you got a look at Gary Ridgway you
know he was killing those girls going
way back didn't become a priority until
the crime wave kind of subsided and
technology kind of caught up and they
said you know what remember that guy's
been king of the green river guy we
should probably catch that guy we can
now yeah we have time to catch him so
they caught it and I think that's kind
of happened a lot and you know and we
kind of go a lot into the original
Nightstalker case and everything you
know particularly since they just caught
him recently through DNA and now they're
going back trying to catch the Zodiac
and stuff
and it should be noted too that the
doodler is one of the cases that is it's
been open the whole time they never
closed it but um he's one of the people
that they're trying to catch yeah a lot
of times we come with these cases you
know it kind of sounds [ __ ] up it kind
of sounds bad that certain people are
marginalized and they don't get police
protection it's not that it's mean it's
it's just that the system just can't
deal with the [ __ ] that's really what it
is you're on your own like I said during
times of high crimes bad back and like I
said particularly at this period in San
Francisco California like I said a lot
of people were moving there and there
was you know a lot of serial killers
were operating the zodiac was still
around there was like a lot of serial
killers operating and I feel like they
couldn't really get a handle on it so
there's like Oh somebody's killing a
bunch of gay dudes yeah they didn't
really care because like I said you know
yet had a triage the situation right
like the doodler is attributed like I
said he's attributed with 14 murders
three attempted murders but there were a
lot more Gaiman during that period that
there were other people what they tend
to be but the only one targeting that
community what the police tended to do
in situations like this is they go to
those gay bars and they show pictures
around the guys that came up missing or
they thought they were dead and they
would just say hey gay dudes somebody's
killing y'all you guys better watch
yourself we can't stop it that's really
how they would cut it well the shitty
cell - and I read a lot we do the same
thing with the hookers they would say
hey hookers guys out there killing you
guys you guys need to stop being hookers
we can't protect you
yeah you're getting into cars with guys
and so these guys are killers although I
should note that the police force at the
time reportedly according to a lot of
the kind of gay papers and stuff like
that at the time we're accusing the
police evidently the police had time to
essentially cruise through the gay
neighborhoods and entrap people with it
yeah but they didn't have time to catch
people that really killing them so
that's nice yeah they would come through
and be like hey baby because sexuality
like I said still illegal at the time so
they would cruise through and like try
to go they'd we position them and then
they would arrest well you know why that
was quick and easy that didn't require
any kind of investigation you don't have
to work and then you could actually get
finds out of them right and make money
off of that in the courts as law
enforcement is it is a business
the business just like everything that's
why you know all about the money you've
got to be you've got to protect yourself
sorry you've got to protect yourself
police are not really did Lily Tomlin
say that no yeah cynical as you get it's
still not so you're still not cover your
own ass but yeah so like I said even
though he's attributed with 14 murders
um usually only five of them are named
now the first one was a guy named Gerald
Cavanaugh now he was 49 he was
originally from Canada they don't know a
great deal about him specifically it
just said you know when they found it
was oh never married whatever they'd
found him on January 24th 1974 lying on
Ocean Beach in San Francisco and he had
been stabbed multiple times
he did have self-defense wounds one
thing that the doodler seemed to do his
kind of Mo was to stab people both in
the front and in the back what he would
do and why they call him the doodler
allegedly is he would go into the gay
bars in the Castro district and he would
ingratiate himself with people by going
hey let me draw a portrait of you or a
caricature of you and people would be
like okay cool and he would draw
pictures of them like on his little
sketchbook or on a cocktail napkin or
what have you and then he would kind of
like you know talk to them and he was
charming and everything like that
he'd be like oh let's go somewhere to a
park or to a beach or you know drive me
somewhere in your car and then he would
end up stabbing them to death multiple
times so that was kind of the thing that
he would do and like I said that's why
they called him to do um I don't think
there was I mean did he make out with
the guys before he killed him I don't
know um some sources say yes some say no
I never saw anything that said any of
them were sexually assaulted um I you
know and there were three people I'm
trying to forget if he's gay um I think
no no because they think the the few
people that escaped him that were
willing to say something even though
they didn't want to be outed
particularly at the time and they so
they wouldn't let their names be known
because a couple of them were evidently
quite famous or quite well known or
primary um yeah it might have been um so
they actually said they thought that he
was probably
straight the interesting thing about it
like I said most serial killers you know
just like they said Silence of the Lambs
most serial killers tend to hunt within
their own ethnic groups this man did not
reportedly this was an african-american
man most reports said that he was very
upper-middle class he seemed a very
educated he was out very nicely dressed
he told a couple of them that he was
studying commercial art they said he
seemed very you know he was he was very
tall slim quite handsome you know and he
was you know good talker smooth talker
stuff like that so but all of his
victims in other words I know that was
his social class he wasn't heard read he
was right in the middle class but
amazing he had some kind of a as here's
the thing that's breaking breaking down
for me why is he going after gay guys
usually usually a serial killer goes
after his intended sexual target again I
think that's why this guy is unusual
because by all accounts most some of the
people that escaped his clutches and
they the cops actually had an unnamed
suspect that they think was probably him
but they didn't have enough evidence to
to convict him so he got let go he would
say things like apparently he was a gay
hater or he had some kind of but most of
the people that escaped perceived him to
be straight they did not think that he
was a gay guy at all so that is another
kind of thing that makes him unusual I
think he sounds yes or he might have
been a self-loathing yeah he might have
been self-loathing gay because evidently
he was in therapy um I don't know if it
was for that issue particularly if it
was the suspect that they were talking
he was gay and he liked white guys and
was blaming them for his gayness that's
what I think was going on that yeah
that's you probably yes you did yeah you
[ __ ] how dare you how dare you be a
tract baby right I'll kill you for
making me gay that's what he said that's
what's going on because I do feel like a
lot of Cisco well a lot of serial
killers are people who do this type of
thing men who do this type of thing they
usually see their victims as like they
blame them a better feeling exactly
that's what's going on so I do feel like
there might be some of that going on how
dare you be hot I'm gonna [ __ ] kill
you yeah making
that might have been yeah I think yeah
now that might go back to something to
where maybe there was some kind of a
molestation that went on between a gay
guy when he was younger and it kind of
tripped some switches and maybe he
started to started to kind of like that
so maybe it was like he liked it he
didn't like it at the same time maybe
yeah
well particularly back then like like I
said I feel like this is probably why
it's better now because it's like you
know no one cares if you're gay anymore
it's like you know it's fine just to
just it's like man it's like mundane now
well yeah it's just like you do you know
[ __ ] I mean it and anybody that would
give a [ __ ] is not worth listening to
anyways yeah so I feel like maybe back
in the day when it was still like
consider when it was still illegal when
it was still like looked down upon you
could really get into some self-loathing
and horrible like guilt kind of [ __ ]
that would make you do some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] it was that was like Toby Toby says
ow man I liked it back he says I liked
it back when being gay was subversive
because you know you know we come from
the goth subculture and we've been in it
since the 80s so there was something
kind of a lot cooler when like nobody
really knew it was because I mean when I
was in high school everyone just thought
it was a Satanist nobody would ya know I
gots her everywhere now there's like
God's everyone's like you see it on you
know Paris runways and you said in
movies and it's not weird anymore so I
can see like a lot of the wound and for
like some leather day rebellion has been
taken out of it but buddy-buddy mine's a
leather daddy you know and yeah and he
says is just too many gay people he
doesn't like him now mainstream he says
this mainstream what cuz he's super into
like Johnson industrial too so yeah so
it's kind of he's like he's like a Rob
Halford he's like he's like he's like
the Gothic Rob Halford yeah he's just
like it up yeah he's and he's I can't he
doesn't look it but he's like it but
he's older than we are but yet it's the
same type of thing and like I said it's
the same thing with the goth subculture
it's like what it's like once it loses
that underground it's you know it's kind
of what happened to like 42nd Street in
New York it's like oh it used to be all
CD with all the porn theater
and you know all the [ __ ] grindhouse
and stuff like that now it's just like a
tourist trap you know I mean it's it's
kind of like that like yeah it was yucky
and dirty and crime-ridden
but there was so much for the hardcore
phew some kind of romance about it yeah
yeah so it's the same thing with the
goth subculture probably the same thing
in the gay subculture of course
according to according to Toby in the
leather daddy sure friends of ours yet
that our cuz you know we have a lot of
friends that are gay that say that
similar kind of thing it's like I used
to be more fun back in the day ones ones
that are our agent older yeah and
they're Goths though yeah and so there
may not know they're not normal gay
people they don't they're they look at
no no but gay people look at them like
they're freaks yeah they're like you
know it's just kind of like we all wear
they dress normal people yeah askance
yeah because I feel like they're hiding
something I always feel like it's the
normal once you get a watch yeah so okay
so Gerald Cavanaugh is generally named
as the first victim of the doodler as I
said stabbed to death in January of 1974
the next one was a much younger he was
27 his name was Joseph Stephens now he
was actually better known as Jay he was
actually quite well-known in San
Francisco because he was a he was a
well-known female impersonator and
comedian he had a recurring gig at a
place called finocchio x' which it was a
club that had been there since the 1930s
so he was kind of well known he was seen
alive they think that he probably drove
whoever the killer was to the spot where
he was discovered this happened in June
of 1974 again he was found on the shores
of Spreckels Lake and had been stabbed
multiple times I think it was three
times and they had found blood like in
his nose and mouth indicating the he had
been stabbed in the lungs the next
victim was actually a German American
man by the name of Klaus Chrisman Klaus
Christian now he actually had a wife and
kids back in Germany but he had been
living in the United States with some
friends for about three months at the
time that he was murdered he was found
dead on July 7th 1974 he had actually
his death was insanely violent he'd been
many many times particularly in the
throat he was found fully clothed
the reason they think that he was maybe
a quote-unquote closeted gay was because
they found an unspecified tube of makeup
in his pocket so I don't know if whose
lipstick or concealer or whatever but
from that they determined that maybe he
was a closeted that's a stretch but what
if that's what I was thinking I was just
like really but you know back then there
like he has a tube of whatever he it was
probably just like chapstick crystal
eyeliner oh yeah like that it's like
like I said I'm very skeptical of that
type of [ __ ] but like I said goth gonna
laugh that's it yeah yeah it's like wow
I was young and pretty I put my [ __ ]
I had her on my powder it's really good
straight out of Duran Duran he would get
an eyeliner yeah yeah and one and a guy
that I used to have a really terrible
crush on back way back in high school
but back in the 1980s he always wore
eyeliner yeah yeah I was a thang back
then back in the 80s and the 90s oh yeah
that kind of thing yeah some dudes can
pull it off I only do it of special
events member lucky we went to the
vampire boy yeah like what yeah it's
like he doesn't usually but yeah if it's
a big special occasion yeah he'll do it
and like I said it looks great you can
bet back in the day [ __ ] dudes would
go to the prom with eyeliner in the
[ __ ] butt in the [ __ ] tuxedos and
[ __ ] yeah remember that yeah yeah and
that yeah that was back in the late
eighties doing that I mean you know at
least where I'm like I went school in
Central Florida so it's still very red
Nike here so people move and they still
got beat up and stuff but it's like yeah
yeah so because this guy had a like I
said unspecified makeup tubes they just
seemed oh well maybe he's a closeted gay
too but whatever so actually he was
murdered they shipped his body back to
Germany to be buried he is considered
the third victim of the doodler the next
one was found in May of 1975 his name
was Frederick Capon and he was 32 he had
actually also been stabbed in the heart
now they identified a couple of these
other of the previous victims they
didn't identify them right away because
for a while they were john doe's this
guy they identified right away because
he'd actually he was a nurse and he had
actually served in Vietnam he had
several medals of commendation
for saving many of his compatriots in
Vietnam so his fingerprints were on
record with the with the army or
whatever or the Navy rather so they knew
who he was
yes so he was the next one that that was
murdered and then the fifth named victim
was named Harold Goldberg he was much
older he was 66 years old he was
originally Swedish although he had lived
in this country for quite a long time
also a sailor I believe he'd been in the
Swedish Navy he had like the tattoos and
everything like that interestingly this
one was a little bit different because
all the other victims had been found
fully clothed this one he was fully
clothed but his pants were unzipped and
if he had been wearing underwear they
were missing so they don't know if the
killer took them no or if he just didn't
have any to start with because common
military tale going commando yeah
everybody knows it's called going
commando but that's the thing that kills
me it's just like I always because I've
written about a couple of cases a couple
true crime cases in my book where they
were talking about how weird it was that
people didn't wear underwear and I'm
like a lot of people don't worry I mean
I'm gonna straighten this out what go on
I don't wear underwear well I don't want
VPL I'm gonna straighten this [ __ ] out
by why it's called going commando why
[ __ ] all right I'm xaf a tree if do you
those you don't know all right you're in
the field and you're in the infantry you
usually carry a rucksack if it's hot
you're [ __ ] sweating constantly
there's no such thing as a shower you
might be out there 30 days all right
underwear is just gonna [ __ ] catch
sweat and it's gonna chafe badly so will
hair soldiers tend to shave you know
they tend to be pornstar smooth all
right well it's practical its much more
practical and you can clean yourself off
with just one of those handy wipes
yeah handy wives come in the MRE all
right you're hot and back in those days
we will have long BDU shirts and that
goes all the way back to 70s in the 60s
the long BDU type shirts if you got
really hot you could unbutton your fly
there's no zippers on military trousers
just buds
you can't see it to get you added
ventilation going commando no underwear
no wonder wearin shaved and like you
said it's really weird that like I don't
know it's really weird that people just
assumed
other people were underwear it's like a
yeah no no and then you know back then
like I said you do especially in the
tight pant if you're living in the wild
actually and you're a commando without
underwear is cleaner than with underwear
yeah you can clean yourself a lot easier
a lot faster better ventilation is like
I said it's just it just seems to me
weird that people would assume that
everybody just wears underwear yeah cuz
they don't so this guy like I said I
don't know if the killer necessarily
took his underwear if he just wasn't
wearing any maybe he was saying he was
military he was going commando that's
what I mean yeah and also he was also he
was European also I mean he'd lived here
for a long time but he was Europeans
Darwin so at this stage like I said they
suspect that the doodler killed 14
people but those five are usually the
only ones named I presume that the other
nine people that they never named were
other gay men that were murdered at the
time that had a similar MO like I said
stabbed in the front in the back usually
the stabbed in the heart stabbed in the
throat something like that and they
usually found them because I believe the
last victim Harold Goldberg they
actually didn't find him for two weeks
they said he'd been laying out on this
you know where they found it for two
weeks in like his face was all covered
with maggots and some like that it's
just as a horrible horrible thing but
that was considered his last victim now
interestingly apparently the cops knew
who it was or had a very strong suspect
evidently they brought this guy in and
they wanted to prosecute him he didn't
confess to any of the crimes but they
thought he was a pretty like he looked
very much like the like the composite
sketch that they made of him and you
know he had a similar kind of thing but
the problem was that the allegedly three
people who were attacked by him and
lived did not want to out themselves by
testifying against him in court because
one of these people was apparently a
European diplomat who had been visiting
San Francisco at the time he was stabbed
six times in his apartment but he
survived no one knows who that is
another one was a quote-unquote
well-known entertainer the gay
community has speculated that it could
be Richard Chamberlain could be Sal
Mineo could be a lot of other actors who
were gay but it wasn't cool to be out
about it back then so they were kind of
keeping it on the DL but they don't know
entirely who that is either now the cops
it seemed like they sort of blamed the
community a little bit for it's like why
we can't prosecute this guy because you
guys won't come out and tell everybody
that you're gay in order to put this guy
in prison
very famous Lee Harvey Milk you know the
very famous you know early gay
politician who was later assassinated by
another politician if you haven't seen
the movie milk it's very good and check
it out um he actually came out and said
that he understood why they were doing
that he's like most of the you know gay
men in San Francisco you know most of
them are still in the closet and their
entire livelihoods their relationships
everything could be lost if they came
out and testified against this guy he's
like so even though it would be nice if
we would catch this guy I can understand
why people don't want to testify against
him because their lives would
essentially be ruined so as I said the
cops said that they knew who this guy
was this guy apparently might have also
assaulted a police officer but I I don't
know a couple of sources said that as
well
but because they claimed that they
couldn't get any people to testify
against him then they had to let him go
because they didn't have sufficient
evidence they do have one single
composite sketch of the suspect he is
said to be an african-american male
about 6-feet tall slender like I said he
was often wore like a navy watch style
cap and they said that he said that he
was studying commercial art that he
seemed very intelligent very educated
but that's about all they ever said they
never named the particular suspect that
they had in and as far as they know
after about autumn of 1976 that he
didn't kill any more people now in 1977
there were these two guys that they
arrested they were from Redondo Beach
and Riverside California and they
actually got questioned there were a
bunch more murders like 28 of them to be
specific that it happened after
quote-unquote homosexual encounters
these guys were also suspects in the
doodler case but were also likewise
never prosecuted or never indicted for
these particular murders now as I said
this guy serial killer is suspected of
killing at least 14 people yet kind of
not a lot of information exists about
him but the case is still open and in
May of 2018 the San Francisco Police
Department came out and said you know
this is one of the active investigations
that we're trying to solve with the new
DNA stuff just like we did with you know
original Nightstalker and the other
crimes that they are still investigating
so we'll see if the doodler ever gets
caught I mean cuz he was pretty young
he's not in the 70s but we'll see how
that goes it won't catch him maybe not
know there so he's probably did it yeah
possibly I mean like I said it seemed
like he did a run but it's hard to say
because like I said so many gay men got
murdered during these particular years
like the mid to late 70s particularly in
this area of California that they're not
entirely sure how many people he killed
it might have been just those five he
came from money I'll tell you that
that's gonna that's they do you think he
did yet he came from money yeah or he
wouldn't have able to move in those
circles they wouldn't have been
attracted to him if he didn't come from
money he'd have to in those days yeah
he'd have to carry himself well so he
came from money you can't fake it those
guys well do all that interestingly to
is that I was reading this really long I
can't murder who write it but this
really long write up about it and he was
kind of like talking about he had
interviewed like a lot of people that
lived in the area at the time that were
closeted at the time and he said it's
interesting just how the mainstream
press pretty much ignored it
he's like the gay press kind of kept up
on it but you know after the last victim
was killed
just you know then you know a few years
after that that's when the AIDS epidemic
started so you know all the news kind of
went to that and he's like plus there
were so many murders of gay men that
it's almost like you couldn't keep up
with all of it
he's like the interesting thing he's
like the race thing was an issue because
he's like particularly back then and I
had never heard this term before but
he's like if you had a black man like
coming into the gay clubs and stuff like
that and you were kind of seen with them
you would become known as like the Dinge
Queen yeah you know what I mean like you
were going after the black guys so like
you said he must have been very smooth
talking he must have you know everything
like I said to you he wasn't from there
he was from another state he was
visiting that area and working in that
area and doing this for a while
and then I think it got too hot and he
left interestingly he usually seemed to
target immigrants or people who were not
from there well you know you know you're
talking about you know these are kind of
quote unquote quote exotic unquote gay
guys these dudes from Europe yeah so if
you asked me I think was attracted to
those guys could be yeah I mean like I
said other than the second victim Joseph
Stevens who actually worked in the area
and was actually quite well known you
know he tended the doodler tended to
target men who were I got from there I
got a feeling you you you need to look
more towards the Midwest Detroit Gary
you know in Ohio is an a/d area that's
probably where he was from well like I
said it was such um there was mud it was
such an influx into San Francisco at the
time particularly they gave immunity
because like I said they perceived that
it was like more welcoming than wherever
they were from there was money in the in
that area in the black community for a
certain time around the 70s it was
vanishing he would have moved yeah
better pastures but maybe his parents
were wealthy or middle-class at least so
then he got goes out to San Francisco
for a while gets involved in this gets
it gets bad the AIDS epidemic hits he
probably knows that maybe blood can kill
you
lien you know goes somewhere else could
be because it seemed like a kind of a
short yeah run unless he killed more
than they thought he wasn't from there
yeah I want to say Detroit Indiana
Michigan Indiana Ohio around that area
that's probably where he came I don't
see I don't think he'd be from New York
because he would stand out as a New
Yorker with this accent that's why I'm
alright so I'm just trying to put get
into his mind yeah but you see Midwest
the accent isn't strong and you can hide
it yeah and you can move into San
Francisco and become a new person there
and blend in which a lot of people were
doing right
I've already do that from New York not
all to become serial killers right a few
of them did garage frightening Lee
enough because they would have percent
well you had a New York accent sound
Brooklyn or you sounded you know yes
that would have stood out so I'm
thinking Midwest that's a that's
actually probably a good sermon yeah
that's good New Orleans Mississippi
Alabama [ __ ] no that accent would stand
out yeah southern accent so yeah Midwest
is really the way I mean other than
those like hardcore like Minnesota
accents but yeah I do I do kind of feel
like that's probably that's probably a
good observation but yet we'll see if
they ever catch this guy like I said
case is still open and it's one of the
ones or so they say that they're trying
to solve nowadays just like they're
trying to solve the zodiac and
everything like that with all the DNA I
don't know very unlikely I don't know
how much DNA evidence they have on this
case like I said I don't know there's
not a hell of a lot of information about
this so I don't know how much DNA
evidence they have I don't know if any
of the victims were sexually assaulted
it doesn't appear that they were and it
also doesn't appear that a lot of them
had sexual relations with I mean
apparently the dual or killed them
before any of that could occur so I'm
not really sure how much he'd be in a
seventies or his 80s I think he's dead
by now he got away with it yeah yeah
anyway let's wrap up the show we've gone
on for long enough as we yeah so
remember if you like this show to like
share subscribe
all your social media and share with all
your friends family and whoever else you
want to share it with if you'd like to
financially support the show you can go
to our patreon page which is patreon.com
slash 13 o'clock podcast or go to our
blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress.com and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account if you'd
like to give a one-time donation also
check out our latest movie review which
was the 2001 film frailty also check out
our last matinee review in which we
reviewed Johnny English strikes again
hunter killer and small foot
that was our movie the movies and that
will probably do it for episode 116 we
will see you next time bye
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]